the world a toast to transatlantic
friendship during better times two years
ago Barack Obama awarded Chancellor
Angela Merkel the Presidential Medal of
Freedom the highest civilian honor in
the US but did Obama know that US
intelligence agencies were tapping
Merkel's phone or was he not aware Obama
has suggested there was no need to
eavesdrop on Germany if I want to know
what Chancellor Merkel is thinking I
will call Chancellor Merkel it seems
miracle isn't the only international
leader who may have been targeted the
list of possible spying victims
continues to grow French president
Francois Hollande protested this week
over allegations that the NSA listened
in on France's embassies Mexico has
ordered an investigation into reports
the NSA hacked president Enrique Pena
Nieto's emails and monitored
communications of his predecessor last
month Brazilian President Dilma Rousseff
vented her anger over us spying in a
speech to the UN General Assembly in New
York well done like many others in Latin
America I fought against
authoritarianism and censorship you know
which is why I will defend without
compromise people's right to privacy and
the sovereignty of my country yeah so
Bella Nia Jimmy o pais if the
allegations are true then the NSA has
been spying on allies and foes alike
here in Germany someone look back at
President Obama's trip to Berlin in June
with less fondness we
can be a little more informal among
friends
you